foreign
from Toronto Canada
this is proud Noir calling from Toronto
I recently turned 20 on my first day
back on campus
um I was nervous most the time because I
understood that the semester ahead was
going to be a heavy in terms of work so
is there a way to have a class load that
makes room for your hobbies I'm
currently enrolled in a four-year
interior design degree program
bachelor's so if there isn't an option
for part-time studies what can full-time
students do in creating a balance with
their hobbies and school
Catherine we sometimes talk about
balance you actually talk about balance
in your book as well and the thing that
I've come to understand is balance is
the default State and we only go seeking
balance when things have become out of
balance there's never like a really
bored person who's in a monastery and
they're meditating all day and they're
saying how do I find more balance yeah
what happens is we Heap on a bunch of
obligations or expectations from other
people and then of course we feel out of
balance and it is only when we feel out
of balance that we then seek balance a
balanced person is never actually
seeking the balance that they have
though it's like riding a bike if you
start riding the bike at first you might
be off balance
but you're not trying to even find
balance there you're trying to ride the
bike and once you've started riding the
bike you're still not seeking balance
you just happen to be balanced right
right I mean balance is a tricky word
because I think in the world of
commercial Wellness
we have created this myopic reductive
version of it where it means being good
at being busy so with you to someone and
particularly women get this message that
oh she's so balanced what you're saying
is not she's hit her sweet spot of
energetic equilibrium which is what
you're talking about the the actual core
definition of balance what you're saying
is she can do a million things and not
drop the ball look at her go and that's
not what balance is and it sounds like
this caller is trying to figure out how
to be good at being busy when I would
suggest her to direct her thoughts
towards the intention of this next
point in her life in these next years
and and the intention is different than
a goal and if your goal is to make
honors and you know also be able to have
gone from beginner to middle level in
exactly three Hobbies then like you can
do that but what's going to be a more
powerful
strategy is to say by the end of college
I want to have been able to say that I
really offered my true self in the
relationship opportunities that I had
whether those were friendships mentors
who you were inspired by romantic
Partners the relationship to yourself
like an intention like that that doesn't
have generic metrics that only you can
say whether you did a good job on that
or not is a much more powerful driving
force than being able to say
I finished my Scroll of a to-do list
I love your use of that word generic too
because that's
precisely what we we become when we
subscribe to a notion of balance that
says I must equally distribute all of my
Creative Energy
across all activities in life yeah well
what am I biased towards yeah right when
I when I look back on my on my college
Years or whatever it is what do I want
to see me having spent more of my time
and energy on what's most rewarding to
me yeah it's so wild that this question
came up because before I
um before this book came out and it came
out last month around November I had
this dream
and I don't dream every night but when I
do I mean you gotta give me a break I'm
a therapist I believe in the power of
dreams right and there have been a
couple of Dreams in my life where I've
been like whoa that is very clear to me
that this is a message from my
unconscious something something's going
on here I need to pay attention to this
and I had this wild dream around
November when I started to feel a lot of
anxiety about you know I'm not a writer
by trade and it's hard to write a book
to say the least and then then the
publicity and promotional part of it is
also just you know getting thrown in the
deep end and I have this dream one night
and all this crazy stuff happens and
that's the end there's a voice that's
not my voice it's like a man's voice and
it said this is your senior year of
college and I wrote it on a sticky note
because what I interpreted that to mean
was my senior year of college I was like
okay I need to apply to these doctoral
programs I need to get my reference
letters from these people I have two
weeks to do this I need to get you know
these grades so that I can get into this
grad school and and if I could just
plant myself back
um on Telegraph street in Berkeley where
I used to live in college and just be
like don't worry about the to-do list
for today and just enjoy yourself that
would have been such a gift and I was so
focused on all this stuff I mean I still
had fun too but I was so over indexed on
getting this stuff done that I didn't
actually enjoy it and it was almost like
coming back that dream was like just
enjoy this you're not gonna get all the
stuff done you're not gonna you know
you're not gonna it's not gonna matter
this is like your senior of college have
fun and so I've been taking that into
all of these interviews and talks and
it's just so much more fun it's so much
I think it feels so much more alive to
just let yourself enjoy the thing you're
doing now
yeah I'm a habitual completionist and
thinking that as soon as it gets
complete yeah then I am complete I think
it started with consumerism with money
like if I just have a certain amount of
money and you realize like oh if you
make fifty thousand dollars a year well
then if you start spending like you have
sixty thousand dollars a year now you're
in debt and so now I'm not complete oh
now I need more money when that doesn't
work it's maybe more stuff will complete
me and when stuff doesn't work then it
is spirituality or it is letting go of
the stuff will make me happy and you
realize like that's just another form of
completionism and completionism is a
form of perfectionism so when you look
at the term perfect if you take it back
to the Latin root purpose air
per meaning completely emphasara meaning
done
Perfection actually means completely
done it does not mean Flawless and we
use the term perfect to
describe completeness all the time like
if you say someone's a perfect stranger
you're not saying that stranger is
Flawless you're saying this this
stranger is complete this person is a
complete stranger to me and
so what perfectionists are seeking is
actually not flawlessness it's wholeness
that is always going to be internally
sourced and when you are not putting
your perfectionism in check you're going
to do exactly what you're saying right
you're going to say I will be whole when
I get this exterior thing like that's
what perfectionism is trying to get your
inner world and your outer world to
match perfectly to be in perfect
alignment and
that can happen
um when you are present but presence is
the only ideal that anyone can ever
actually achieve because when you're
present you are accepting the reality of
what is and you're also in a space of
accepting the possibility of what could
be
and that's why perfectionists
gravitate towards presence so much but
the problem is they try to reverse
engineer it like oh and my house is all
clean and the Windex isn't behind the
cup and then this is here and this you
know then I'll feel whole relaxed joyful
perfect not resentful at all like all
the stuff we feel when we're present so
that's a really powerful Game Changer of
like you already are perfect you're
already completely done you're a whole
human being you always have been that
makes you automatically worthy of all
this stuff there is no need to try to be
something you already are you don't need
to try to win stuff that already belongs
to you
the point is to enjoy it did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free